pensemos en cómo encontraríamos la
pendiente de la línea tangente a esta
curva dada por la gráfica de una función
y que sea justo aquí en el punto x igual
a entonces hemos visto esto con la
definición de derivada ahora vamos a
buscar una función que nos dé la
pendiente de la línea tangente en cada
punto que a nosotros se nos ocurra por
ejemplo si nos tomamos un x arbitrario
digamos aquí este x ahora vamos a pensar
en qué pasa o bueno si si tomamos ese
punto aquí entonces este punto de la
gráfica es x coma f x muy bien entonces
nos interesa saber cuál es la pendiente
de la recta tangente en ese punto y para
eso vamos a tomarnos un punto que esté
más alejado de de x digamos este que sea
un x más h y también nos fijamos en el
punto que se encuentra sobre la gráfica
dado por x + h coma
de x + h muy bien este es un punto sobre
la gráfica y ahora consideramos la línea
secante que une estos dos puntos digamos
porque se quedó un poco un poco chueco
pero vamos a hacerlo un poquito mejor y
más o menos ahí se ve que se cante
verdad va por debajo de la curva
entonces para calcular la pendiente de
esta recta secante pues simplemente
tenemos que dividir el incremento en la
dirección vertical y el incremento entre
el incremento en la dirección horizontal
entonces el incremento en la dirección
vertical pues no es otra cosa más que
en x + h y le restamos lo que teníamos
originalmente que es f x muy bien y todo
esto ahora lo dividimos entre el
incremento en la dirección horizontal
que es x + h x + h - menos x muy bien
entonces de hecho estas dos x se pueden
cancelar esta se cancela con esta otra
verdad y entonces así es como nos queda
esta definición del límite perdón de la
pendiente dejar recta secante y estoy
pensando en límites porque ahora
necesito que este punto x + h se
aproxime tanto como yo quiera a este
punto x para que así esta recta secante
se vaya convirtiendo poco a poco en la
pendiente bueno la pendiente de la recta
secante poco a poco se convierte en la
pendiente de la recta tangente entonces
para que esto se aproxime a x lo que
necesitamos es hacer que esta h se
parezca cada vez más a 0
entonces utilizamos
cuando h tiende a 0 de todo esto y si
este límite existe esto es justamente a
lo que le vamos a llamar la derivada de
f evaluada en x muy bien para x
arbitrario y eso es una función de x tú
me das una equis y yo te voy a escupir
el valor dado por este límite y que
sabemos que es la pendiente de la recta
tangente muy bien y eso en cualquier
punto x ahora bien nosotros dijimos que
queríamos la pendiente en el punto a así
que pues necesitamos calcular esto en el
punto a es decir queremos calcular la
derivada en a y eso no es otra cosa más
que el límite cuando h tiende a cero y
en vez de poner x voy a poner la verdad
entonces déjenme deje no escribirlo así
efe de algo más h menos
efe de algo sobre todo eso sobre h muy
bien y ese algo pues dijimos que lo
queremos evaluar en a verdad estamos
calculando en nada entonces aquí tiene
que ir una
muy bien
con rojito y esta definición es la
pendiente de la recta tangente en el
punto a ahora podemos hacerlo de otra
forma y que es hacerlo directamente
verdad por ejemplo tenemos aquí esto
vamos a considerar un punto cualquiera
digamos digamos este x vamos a tomarnos
este x y consideramos este punto sobre
la gráfica que es x coma
fx y ahora pensamos en la recta secante
nuevamente que une a estos dos puntos
verdad el punto morado y el punto rojo
entonces para calcular la pendiente de
esa recta secante pues hacemos lo mismo
la diferencia en la componente vertical
que es f x menos f de a muy bien todo
esto sobre x
x menos
- esta es la definición del límite
perdón la verdad la definición de la
pendiente de esta recta secante ahora si
hacemos que este x se aproxime muchísimo
al al punto a entonces calculamos el
límite cuando x tiende a a y esta
definición también es equivalente a lo
que es la derivada solo que ya le
estamos evaluando directamente en el
punto que nos interesa que está muy bien
entonces la secc ante la próxima y la
pendiente de la recta secante está dada
por esto así que cuando metemos el
límite se convierte en la pendiente de
la recta tangente lo que es
esencialmente la derivada ok entonces
tuvimos dos formas para calcular esta
derivada una digamos que es en general y
luego ya sustituimos en el valor que nos
interesaba y lo hacemos en este punto
particular pero esencialmente estas dos
definiciones hacen lo mismo